it wasn't welcome to this video was a
little bit do we have that software
actors but I think I'm online now ok and
yeah this video is a little bit out of
the ordinary because I'm going to talk
about to see here upcoming projects yeah
this is about a preview of the next
couple of month maybe until yeah early
mid 2018 because I'm working on a couple
of things that are in development um and
it's not enough process I'm working on
this and I'm switching to other things
yeah and only yeah over the course of
the next couple of months it will be
determined what would be released on
what platform and in whatever I want to
tell you about a couple of things that
I'm sure will be will be released and
the next thing that I'm going to be um I
going to be releasing will be on
untestable definitely and it will be a
wide repertoire - based on when you form
and this is an important project for me
because of my chess teaching activities
many students do play 1.e4 and I am NOT
by nature 1d for play and myself I have
not played that all that often in
tournament chess maybe 10% of my games
and it's hard to say I've played a
couple of you four games when I was
younger and I now nowadays do that on
and off once in a while so I want to I
develop currently Andy for base
repertoire for white um and it's
something that is of course then I would
just about to buy but also something
that I do for me for myself to get some
info on knowledge that I can maybe pass
on
my students the idea of this repertoire
by the way will be m2 has also probably
be the title to keep it simple it won't
be a super sophisticated super
complicated
efore bass repertoire I'm going to
select lines that are relatively easy to
learn and not all that complicated this
is I think a very sensible approach
first of all it's rather difficult to
get anything with the complicated lines
a hell yeah
for a for example I'm going to give you
an example so if you have this one
before you have double King pawn here
White has a huge choice and of course
you can go super main line with Bishop
b5 the the Widow pass the Spanish but at
the end you have this big question to
answer what are you doing against the
villain it's not a big thing in the club
level though but also in the main lines
what are you going to do if you play the
absolutely main aisle
this is a ton of theory and I mean
Black's moves are super natural so very
likely you will get all the main lines
and one the other big issue of course is
a Sicilian when the most principal stuff
is definitely open but this is a
fantastically complicated bond your
theory and my repertoire is aimed at
players starting on the let's say 15
1600 level which doesn't mean you can
reduce it yet if you are a stronger
player I actually plan to use this e4
repertoire myself in some games and I
want to suggest lines that are easier to
learn and and handle and still contain a
little bit of poison if at some point
you decide the choices you are not sharp
enough for you you can still switch to
something sharper and to keep the
recommended repertoire suggestion as a
really sound solid alternative that you
can always fall back to I can give you a
quick overview what to see 45 over 12
will have and here for example I'm going
to go form the four Knights game and
going to go scotch so it will be a
scotch for Knights this system in recent
years has gained quite some optionality
due to chronic adapting it in a couple
of games this is a system that is very
very easy for Y to learn I think it's a
matter of you have just just really
quick study to get the key ideas and
then you have a super reliable opening
system that and this is really what I'm
thinking about with this kind of
approach that is very easy to play like
here you have the super solid pound pawn
structure there is no weakness on the
white side you have an easy development
this is the attitude that I have towards
the repertoire should present you with
something that you can learn but if you
forget some things yeah then it's not
like you're sitting in some kind of mess
where you've got I don't know two pawn
sacrifice and you'll remember what's
going on this should not happen at least
not regularly it's very tough to avoid
mmm complications all together and in
fact you shouldn't do that if the
opponent for example play something
unsound and you can have to punish it
with sharp play of course you have to do
it but what I won't do is actively seek
the most complicated approach and this
is an approach here with the four knives
has an advantage by the way in regards
to the to the petrol to the Russian
defense it's completely play 93 so you
don't need something extra against the
petrol this is the main thing with e4 e5
or other u45 lines are basically a
second rate anyway
Theodore's is quite decent but you have
simple recipes against that when you can
hope to get a slight advantage the
Sicilian is Sicilian I will go Knight f3
and with opt for the Bishop b5 on line
here the rustle demo variation against
96 this is nowadays actually the main
line on the professional level they play
that more then then d4 the open and the
good thing about this line is that is a
very common-sense heavy opening now you
develop you castle quickly
you have a safe King and it's easy again
easy to play against d6 I would also
play the should be 5 very lightly
I'm currently considering a second
option but I have to see it is a work in
progress but most likely I will go for
the check it is a very fitting partner
opening to the rasoolum oh yes c6 I'm
not yet decided what I will do there are
a couple of options I'm even thinking
about this is a tough decision about
recommending to play d4 here this is the
open of course but it is a very limited
set of lines there is no dragon there is
no Nigel there is no special eikhoff and
so on so it is something that I feel
it's not an unreasonable idea because
ultimately you should master the open
Sicilian if you play one year for this
the most principled and in many ways the
most interesting way to take on the
Sicilian so it's maybe not a bad idea to
get this sort of position type into your
repertoire but play it in a way that you
have a limited subnet or set subset of
lines to study this is yet not yet
decided there are many other things like
93 or Serie B 3 those moves are very
reasonable
six so I have to see in what I'm doing
them um what else is there yeah these
are the two big big chunks c5 and e5 we
have the Carroll of course and here I'm
very sure what I'm going to recommend
because I think it this the two knights
is what I play there myself and I think
it's a very very reasonable choice for
white White has some very good chance I
think to maintain a slight pool and
oftentimes due to the fact that black
will play Bishop g4 and after h3 will
concede the pair of bishops this is
something that you can always hope to
exploit in the long run again this is
solid and the pyro is very solid for
black but it is not it's not something
that automatically simply equalized I
believe so the two knights will be the
choice against the Carroll and it gets
the French defense I'm currently working
on bond and on some options the French
is not so easy to tackle the problem
with it is a little bit if you want to
present somewhat as I mentioned easy to
learn simpler repertoire you have the
problem here that black is very very
flexible in the French due to the closed
nature of the position you can actually
afford many things with black that are
not downright terrible but probably need
to slight advantages for white but with
complex positions and it is such a slow
opening edit for example against moves
like 92 or 93 yeah I mean of course
everybody knows that main line is c5 and
9006 but when you look a little bit
deeper you see that there is Bishop d7
which is very reasonable there is a
knight c6 again very reasonable there is
a six which is wrong
I played that quite a bit there's even H
six yeah so it's absolutely crazy
because of the closed type of position
black can play all kinds of stuff and it
can easily get somewhat yeah somewhat
messy yeah with move orders and
transposition so it's not an easy thing
to do 93 it's a bit sharper but here you
are dealing with very very specific
positions that are quite tricky to
understand yeah for example after Bishop
before white most likely will play five
and it will be Alex technically this
kind of thing it will be sharp and very
complicated
we deal um with them a situation that I
sometimes call yeah this is a non
symmetrical case of knowledge of both
sides while black is playing the French
maybe every single game after one year
four so that will probably amount to 50%
or more of its games we will not play
the French with white all that water and
it is a very tricky opening because of
the closed position so I'm currently
undecided what to do against the French
I actually have some interesting ideas
and it's a little bit funny to give that
option but I actually have some
interesting ideas in the exchange
variation I know that this sounds
extremely stale but I don't think it is
that stale actually because why term
with the the right to move have some
ideas available to actually transform
this position into something that is
actually quite interesting so there are
some options and even the exchange is
one of them I'm not really sure it is a
little bit of a strange idea but I was
surprised that there I actually really
some questions that you can ask like
yeah then what else is there these are
the four big openings and I think the
rest you don't have to worry about all
that much even though I can tell you
what I'm going to
recommend against v6 lists okay black
has inside and so on but all this can be
handled with yeah let's say simple
reasonable rules against the guts I will
probably go for Bishop III based
approach and there are some interesting
ideas related I mean it's very much
removal a sensitive you want like a
story but there are many interesting
ideas related to yeah I'm just going to
show you the general idea related to h3
this is keeping the night away and then
go with f4 later that combination is
quite interesting this way we don't have
we don't have the night on a three
already at the click Bishop III
discourages c5 approaches by black if
you play the regular f4 line like it's
always able to play c5 very early on
that isn't also easy to work Bishop III
nine there are also some ideas related
to a quickie five for example um in this
kind of situation it's not such a great
idea to play d5 after e5 white is quite
substantially better already
we prepare the e5 push so this is a
quite poisonous system I think against
you can also play this setup like here
against the modern defense the main
difference is that here black can go for
quick a6 b5 without the night and played
out to f6 this is still quite quite ok
for white you can even play a four here
and put a bishop here there are some
some options that make sense so this is
a the main approach against the d66
stuff that leaves the L accounts which
is something I will talk about a little
bit later in this video and this is
something where I'm going to recommend
right line approach for white not play
the absolute main line the best line
against the other kinds is actually this
and actually quite clearly this is the
best move the best line the problem with
it is however and again this is
something that I will talk about in the
later in the video is that black after
Knight f3 has a whole host of lions
he's got Bishop g4 with some sub
variations that actually are different
with e6 and c6 there is g6 there is 96
which requires special knowledge and
there is d5 which is the modern mainline
it after Knight takes there is c6 there
is 97 there is g6 yeah so it's quite
interesting that in the other coins
there is a real bunch of different lines
that black can choose and this makes a
mainline approach I think quite tricky
to do because you will get the elegance
defense maybe and once I know every two
years or so it's depending on how many
games you play and it makes sense
- I think recommend something which is a
non mainline it might make it might be
the case that black equalizes in this
case but this is really not not the
point then you have to just play a game
yeah with from equal position playing
something more principled against the
other kinda requires lots of work and
very likely you will have forgotten what
you've looked at when you face the
opening for real
I mean in some cases you know that your
opponent plays and then you can still
specifically prepare something if you
feel and offbeat choice is not good but
there are some of the choices that are
perfectly reasonable and I'm currently
not quite sure what I'm going to
recommend as there are a couple that
actually makes sense
um I forget we made at the Scandinavian
I'm sorry yeah well there's d5 I forgot
about that one
and it's actually it would open access
Canadian and yeah of course I will
recommend to capture and yeah in term I
think I'm after three d5 we have to go
what we should go probably 93 and then
check the three three most a greedy 826
connect I've I think it is pretty clear
that in the Scandinavian defense a black
were probably not fully equalized but
it's not something substantial and it's
very playable for black so disregard it
is fairly easy for white to recommend
something that is easy to learn still
maintain a slight pool so yeah I will
probably just play Knight c3 year in the
repertoire and go from there it's not
yet something that I looked at I'm
currently working at this project
invested most time in each 525 and one
c5 as these are the most principal
replies but it is a work in progress the
estimated release date for this project
is in roughly two to three months so so
that you get an idea and roughly two to
three months I would have a vacation
coming up soon roughly three weeks and
probably during the vacation I will if I
have some yes if I'm up for it I will
work a little bit on that and maybe
finish the whole thing so this is the
project that will be released soon as
and what else is on the plate and there
are actually there are two now actually
three free black repertoire projects or
I can actually flipping the left
to adjust the study orientation with
black I have three projects in the
making thinking about doing them or
worked on them to some degree it is not
yet clear what will be released at what
date but I can tell you what it is it is
actually something with black against
before and I actually have three
different things that I'm working on one
is in fact the El accounts yeah this is
not a surprise I've mentioned that I'm
working on that its own completely our
fifty collected opening which is not as
bad as it sometimes is if some we are
called
out to be in fact I don't quite think
that people who think that is the second
rate I never looked at it I think that
of course we have to be honest they're
wider is probably able to maintain a
small advantage but it is not um
something dramatic at all and it's
exactly what I mentioned before you will
always be if you play this opening and
have studied is you will have an
information advantage over your opponent
because he never gets it on the board
like never yeah I have witnessed this a
lot yeah with people that I know playing
my ala cons they get it on the board and
their opponents is just blank most of
the time actually and this is I'm
talking about more than 50% of the games
they get 93 and here black has yeah more
than one decent option to play for
equality so it is a quite interesting
opening to look at especially because it
has this big surprise value there is one
project the other project is again one
of those keep it simple record to us and
focus on easy to learn this is by the
way not so much the case of the other
con I don't think the other kind is an
especially easy to
opening because there is the odd line
that white can play that is sharp and
you need to know it especially the four
pawns attack this is an opening line
that it's in fact not that fantastic for
white but the path to equality is very
narrow and you have to know it in detail
it's just it's very tough to just play
it and think okay I'm going to find that
over the board's really tough and okay
what is the second thing that I'm
looking at for black it is
unsurprisingly maybe one leaf I am I'm
thinking about it keep it simple
approach repertoire based on the double
King pawn if I've is arguably the
absolute main line especially at the top
level and they all play double King pawn
and this is a project that of course I
think will be in high demand because
people like good sound solutions and
five it's just really really sound
decision and I have some ideas for this
repertoire but not yet something that
I'm willing to share here because they
are not that settled with the e45 wide
repertoire I know about ninety percent
eighty ninety percent of the lines that
I'm going to choose with this I am
reasonably sure but I'm not yet ready to
tell because I don't want to get the end
say okay you know whatever having
problems II okay then I'm doing
something something completely different
in any mainline are opening you have
such a wide choice it's not like you
cannot play a single thing yeah like you
let's say if somebody said I cannot play
the Petroff because of this red line
this is not not true we can play all
kinds of things in the Spanish for black
you can play probably one of twenty
systems so there's a really wide choice
so I'm not going to yet not not yet able
to
what I'm going to choose at the end and
the first option again black against you
form it's something that I'm working on
is a Sicilian based repertoire and this
will most likely most likely be based on
the accelerated dragon this is also
something that I feels interesting yeah
this'll accelerate its dragon the good
thing about this opening is that it is
very versatile as you can build an
opening repertoire for black also
against one see for around it stem if
you know to how to play against and me
Roxy binds here in this line it is
fairly easy also to reply it against c4
that with c5n g6s the only real option
for white to play for an advantage is to
transpose into the maracas see it's the
same position and in the Sicilian move
order of course um we have here the main
alternative Knight c3 but this I feel is
something where black has a number of
good options actually that they can
choose from so this would be a
repertoire based on one c5 thus leading
to the a non symmetrical positions from
the get-go one in five of course is
symmetrical for black very solid but it
is again rather symmetrical and not as
fighting from the get-go as a dragon
style Sicilian so this is another
project I have some work done on that
but it's not something that's going to
release the soonish the other project
that definitely will happen I mean I
don't know at that point but it will
the album is a default based repertoire
for white also on that keep it simple
approach so a full repertoire based on
deform that will try to choose lines
that are based on natural simple to
understand moves nothing overly fancy
when you play something super
complicated that just cannot really
understand all that easily I have some
thoughts on that of course what I'm
going to do but again this is not
something where I want to quote closed
lines yet because is not it is to to
wait yet but it will definitely happen I
think all this should be expected in the
course of the next couple of months
there may be until like March April next
year I don't know
I'm maybe too optimistic but I want to
get some things released also mind it's
it's just what it is I want to update
some of my knowledge yes so that I can
recommend better things to students and
get to learn new things and releasing
such a repertoire is something that
helps in multiple ways yeah so I hope
you've got some good ideas what I'm
working on and what I'm going to release
in them in the near future or in the not
so near future
I'm happy to hear your feedback on the
projects if you have ideas about
something else entirely I'll be I'll be
happy to learn about it yeah thanks for
watching